the U.S federal reserve has again raised
its key interest rate by three quarters
of a percentage point to
3.75 percent
it's the latest in a stream of
aggressive rates hikes aimed at bringing
inflation under control U.S prices are
rising at a rate not seen since the
1980s fed chairman Jerome Powell says
even more rate hikes are likely and that
will take its toll on economic growth
restoring prices European shares
reactored negatively to the news we can
talk to polish meeting about that he's
Chief Economist at berenberg economics
we already knew the FED would raise
rates we already knew our recession is
around the corner why then are equities
falling
because the FED said last night that it
expects to raise rates by more than it
had expected before that so the FED
message was rates have to go up a bit
further than initially expected and the
markets are reacting to that having said
that in my view this should not have
been such a great surprise as we were
anyway expecting the FED to go to four
to five percent rather than stopping at
4.6 as the FED had previously indicated
in September
central banks in Europe are also
fighting inflation with rate hikes and
the cost of living crisis is said to be
so much more acute in the UK where you
are why is that
simply because Europe including the UK
are heavily exposed to Russia to the
Russian gas shortage and as a result we
have a problem in Europe the U.S does
not have the U.S has fracking hence in
our on our side of the Atlantic The
Squeeze on the Disposable incomes of
consumers from high energy prices is
much worse than in the US in the US we
have a largely homegrown inflation in
Europe both the Eurozone and the UK
inflation is mostly the consequence of
Putin's brutal war against Ukraine okay
so the U.S has its cheap Shale oil but
while inflation continues to erode
living standards in slow economic growth
uh the world over despite all of these
rate hikes is it perhaps time to try
something else
well rate hikes will help in the U.S
where we do have homegrown inflation
rate hikes in Europe will not help very
much because they cannot bring down the
prices for gas for electricity and the
like rate hikes this side of the
Atlantic are supposed to contain
inflation expectations that is to make
sure that inflation doesn't spread much
further but the main tool over here to
combat the cost of living crisis is of
course government intervention
government subsidies to all those who
need it the households and the companies
who need it well taking a look at the
situation now a government's doing
enough
by and large I would say they are doing
enough in the UK with the energy price
cap for households they are doing
actually quite a bit more than most
other European countries ultimately we
cannot spare people the pain we can just
make sure that those least able to Bear
the pain don't have too much pain to
bear that is by and large what
governments can do ultimately we will
probably have to run this winter
recession have to run let it run its
course before then from Spring onwards
it will probably get much better
bearing this the pain not sparing the
pain you heard from the chief Economist
at bergenback economics hogash meeting
thank you very much for your analysis on
that new West rate hike
you're welcome
I'm now joined by my colleague from UW
business Cassandra Sun Cassandra so
what's the Hope here why is the Fed
raising interest rates again the Federal
Reserve really has two goals uh in their
mission statement right it's keep
inflation low and ensure maximum
employment and uh so far the keep
inflation low part has really not been
met when you look at the three most
recent months where data is available
inflation has been over eight percent in
July August and September that's nearly
four times the goal rate so inflation
has been a problem and it's been a
problem for over a year so the Hope here
is that continuing to raise rates will
slow inflation it makes it a little bit
harder for folks normal people like you
and me but also businesses to borrow
money let's say you're looking to make a
big ticket purchase buy a car for
example if the interest rate to take out
a loan to borrow the car is higher you
might consider delaying that purchase or
you might get a cheaper vehicle right
and if that happens it could slow demand
and if it slows demand the hope is that
everyone's hoping is that that will put
pressure on sellers to not only to
possibly keep the price the sticker
price as is or maybe even lower it
so what's the global ramifications this
is not only important for people in the
U.S this has Global ramifications that's
right
um the U.S is the world's biggest
economy and other central banks are
going to be looking to the Federal
Reserve and they could possibly follow
suit so those are impacts we could be
seeing quite soon but there are other
impacts that could be felt because but
this is a very complicated web the UN
for example has signaled that they're
unhappy with the trend of rate rises
from the U.S they have said in the past
that this trend of rate Rises that this
policy from the Federal Reserve could
actually have more could actually
inflict more damage globally than the
financial crisis in 2008 and more damage
possibly than the covid-19 shock of
2020. so there's a lot that could happen
here but we have seen some impacts
already that's because a lot of
countries they use the US dollar as
their Reserve currency so some bigger
impacts that we're already seeing and
then these are complicated webs but some
impacts we're already seeing in Nigeria
and Somalia the strong dollars pushing
up the price of imported food Fuel and
medicine so there could be a lot to come
thank you very much Cassandra Santa from
DW business